in five four three two one
I knew my co everybody is unlike a
konichiwa
whatever hey you know what was really
cool but when I was in New York I we
were doing send foods and we were doing
this thing do you know this thing like
this Japanese thing where they take this
white bean and it's like a sweet dessert
but they do like spring designs on it so
when a springtime they'll take the white
bean and add like food coloring into it
and they'll make like a sweet bean
dessert with red bean inside oh [ __ ]
no it's very pretty so they do
specifically for spring and so we
intended it for us and foods episode but
the person that I was talking to I
didn't know I was talking like [ __ ]
Japanese New York royalty you know her
and her husband or the first people to
ever open up a Japanese restaurant in
New York how old were they he's like in
her late 60's Wow yeah like 60s or 70s
so husbands might be a little older but
they own about 17 to 18 restaurants and
they're a restaurant group out there so
I have her contact cuz they want to
collaborate with people who do matcha so
she owns like a tea store called cha New
York so definitely gonna contact them
and so cuz we have presentations about
Claude Jun be but it was interesting
because I didn't know who I was talking
to like there they were like the [ __ ]
[ __ ] opened up 17 [ __ ] store
restaurants awesome in in in New York
off just family-owned huh all family
only did it all themselves you know who
else was Japanese royalty who well
American Japanese American [ __ ]
Richard alkies dad oh really he's the
father of Benihana dude what yeah what
the how did you find that out I mean no
Steve oh yes Richard oh he's his dad
yeah
cuz I know of Richard Aoki like back in
a day like it was I'm realistic
he's like you know Donald Trump's kind
of the Japanese Donald Trump kind of guy
like very flashy very like new money
right he had multiple like different
divorces with hot model wives and
whatever and Steve Aoki is one of the
kids from that and so was Devin Aoki the
girl that was on fast and furious and
she was a model and stuff I don't know
they were related
Steve Aoki looks like he just makes
Japanese swords for the Imperial Army
Japanese Jesus Dave yeah but yeah he's
so his dad made a fortune on Benihana
and Benihana
from what I hear back in the day in the
70s or whatever it was a classy spot
like it wasn't the [ __ ] spot that we
know of today yeah it wasn't a kid
restaurant it was no family restaurant
it was like Vegas like you go there in
the who's who's and the [ __ ]
celebrities they're all there you know
when when I first had teppanyaki I was
kind of disappointed not because of the
the flashy show stuff that was very
entertaining but when I've eaten the
food I was like whatever yeah the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did I pay for I heard he
was premium though and like back then
back then III had teppanyaki in this
restaurant in New York I can't remember
but it was on a cent foods episode but
the teppanyaki that they had was really
good they train their staff really well
they had like Wagyu beef and stuff so it
was it was cooked really well
but when I like Benihana I think is good
too but you know when when I have
Japanese food I think about very
composed dishes but this one just seemed
like stir-fry with the show yeah I mean
in Benihana is a American invention yeah
because I think his dad Richard Aoki
he's a real estate guy you and I think
he used to have a food truck or whatever
it was and back in the day he came up
with this idea of a performance show and
he's just like man people think Japanese
people are [ __ ] samurais or whatever
let me just [ __ ] her up and you know
just uh figure why people believe
anything is that you want to see a
volcano you like that it was kind of
cool because you know because Mariel
speak so much Japanese and then um like
I learned Japanese in high school and
then afterwards I continued it when she
was speaking to me it was so funny
because as she was speaking Japanese I
was responding back to her to English
and she's like you speak Japanese I'm
like no I just know what you're saying
you know just because I like hear that
now but it is interesting it's like is
Mariel a polygon yes for sure I think
the English Korean Chinese Japanese yeah
so she speaks four fluently and then
well it's not she's kind of losing some
of it because she doesn't practice it
anymore but she could still read write
and
Wow you know that's the crazy part is
that most people when they could speak
it they can't read and write in it she
could read and write in all of them
that's pretty crazy
yeah I might try to learn something I
gotta I gotta just hurry up and finish
Japanese at this point because I was
being lazy now like I really do want to
learn Japanese it's the way that we're
learning it's [ __ ] it up so I watched
his video on how people acquire language
and polygons have their own like
different people have different styles
like some guys they like flashcards some
guys they like grant like like learning
the grammar some guys just like immerse
themselves in the culture like they'll
go off into the streets of Thailand and
just talk to people and like remember
some words there's different methods
right but this one guy figured out a
method and I think it was pretty genius
denzler no no no it's like a new method
and he there's a video on YouTube but
basically there's five levels that the
US government kind of created in
difficulty of languages right and the
way that they figured it out was they
did a huge survey and all this stuff and
so the US government came out with
basically the first level of difficulty
for native English speakers not
bilingual yeah so we wouldn't fall in
the secatur category but a native
English speaker with no knowledge of any
other languages how difficult it would
be the first level would be all the land
Latin languages it would take about 600
hours or so for them to be fluent in
this language Spanish Romanian
Portuguese French and Italian those are
the Latin Romance languages right and
it's the closest to English with similar
words right so it's easy for us to
understand the second would be German
the third I forgot I forgot what it was
but the third and fourth is basically
most languages in the world
from Vietnamese to like Russian or
whatever right but the level 5 for
native English speakers is Arabic
Japanese Chinese Korean and something
else
oh yeah it's actually the opposite so
it's
the most difficult in pronunciation and
sentence structure and all that for
native English speakers yeah so since
this guy knows a few Asian languages he
thought he would go for Arabic because
Arabic is supposed to be really freaking
hard and he shows how to acquire this
language and then the way he did it was
basically he was super fluent and he got
his hours in but the first thing he did
was he got a magazine and he asked his
tutor to just point at the images and
talk and the whole system is based off
of ninety percent that language you're
trying to learn and ten percent English
the ten percent English is only to talk
in between to go this is what we're
gonna do next we're just gonna point out
all of this and say they say the words
and you do that and then they'll ask you
yes or no questions and he's like you
gotta acquire language like a baby
acquires language the way adults talk to
you the adults talk to you very easy
they talk you kind of cute
they don't use high vocabulary they'll
be like this is a car it's blue
you know like they'll say [ __ ] like that
so he's like you have to find your
language parents so you got to find pant
like your parents that are gonna spend
hours with you explaining [ __ ] to you
telling you stories so it's combination
of listening to stories watching imagery
and identifying vocabulary with imagery
and you do that for many many hours yeah
and then you have to have someone who
will interact with you in that language
mmm yes he acquired it like easy dude I
was like wow I think that's what what
Meredith was trying to do for me I just
got really irritated because she's like
she she would speak to me very sitting
like very simple stuff yeah but then all
that happened was getting irritated
because I wanted to go into deeper
conversation but I couldn't do it maybe
you learn differently yeah because
there's a guy out there that his style
is all he does is like he walks up to
the local and then he'll know one word
and he'll use that one word hmm
like if it's hi hi I didn't know
whatever they respond he tries to absorb
that mm-hmm
there's another guy that so there's
about 500 words and phrases or were
that you can use in combination in most
languages
once you learn and memorize these 500
you can probably speak fluently so he
spends basically he could spend like 24
hours or whatever learning these 500
things and then they become pretty good
at just like combining those things and
they can have a conversation and when
they start having conversations they
pick up more statements and phrases and
whatever I really do want to learn like
a third language so bad just so I could
what would you do I think number one I
think it's just really cool that you
could speak another language that's like
and I think there's just been so many
times where I could have used the
language that I was interested in and I
just because I didn't do the time for it
I didn't know it like there's so many
times I could I could have spoke
Japanese or Spanish and I just didn't
learn the [ __ ] language you know
what's crazy is that there's so many
similarities in like Spanish Romanian
and it Italian you know just like those
languages have the same language yeah
yeah
yeah like the solut like things like
that yeah it's like damn but even like
for us like Jimmy like we've heard asian
language in me in chinese and japanese
and korean same thing Jun Bay Jim be and
Jimmy which is kind of interesting to
like I I seems like that mother language
is like Chinese for most of it right
Cantonese maybe yeah yeah cuz even for
like Korean people like me on is like
noodles Mian whose noodles in Chinese so
it's all the same he's like it's a de
ribbon and that made for us yeah well
not don't like udon that's different
yeah we also have salt but we have like
so men round man it's men yeah a lot
done yeah yeah we have stuff like that
to just get into the topic today people
this one right here let's see if she
wants us to mention her name or not
doesn't so we'll talk we're gonna tell
everybody your name I hope you're ready
for this [ __ ] yeah but her name is
pretty F she didn't get the full name so
it's good so this is from patreon Liz
see this was around Christmas so we're
gonna move past that but either way the
topic is great
she's like christmas is coming up super
late but she says my boyfriend I will be
going to spend
you days at his parents house for the
holidays don't get caught like a dick
yeah what's that sometimes it's actually
kind of nice when you do go to your your
like parents or whatever cuz you had
like secretly [ __ ] it makes it exciting
again what's that noise it sounds like
using a lot of lotion in there like she
goes my issue was dealing with his mom
uh-oh spaghetti oh she's not a bad
person
cool I hope she is quite the opposite
actually she has a great heart and is
kind and warn to everyone the only
problem is she has terrible etiquette
that's the only problem what what dish
what does she mean by etiquette listen
what did she do she farts while you're
eating Doug she would literally open her
mouth wide to burp she Cantonese lifts
her butt off the seat to fart is she my
mom and talk in detail about her bowel
movements this is my mom are you talking
[ __ ] about my [ __ ] mom right now
[ __ ] is that what you're saying
you're saying that's inappropriate you
sound like a [ __ ] prude [ __ ]
how about that I'll give you hell of
defensive that's not like my mom bill
your mom's that hardcore well my mom is
should she'll rip it all out dog let me
tell you about my mom's dude like there
my mom is so [ __ ] hilarious up until
about I say three years ago she finally
decided to drink lactaid I had been
trying to convince this woman that she's
lactose intolerant but she's like no I
drink milk I'm fine I'm like it's just
cuz you drink it it doesn't mean that
you're not allergic to lactose every
time you drink milk it smells like a
skunk [ __ ] the carcass [ __ ] Oh some
moose ate it died and that carcass [ __ ]
itself as well that's what it smells
like dog she has [ __ ] she [ __ ] once
farted so bad
my aunt smelled it she ran to the
bathroom and threw up my walk through
she goes oh my god and she run and she's
frozen in the bestest I so my mom's just
dying laughing I'm cracking the [ __ ] up
so it's like Bart's farts dog it's it
might battle Bart sparks
bad especially when she drinks milk so
now she starts she starting to drink
lactaid because she understands that she
has a lactose intolerance to lactose so
my mom is she's from like this area
called Toledo and Toledo is like a super
country area are they known for their
farts she probably did country ass
[ __ ] bumpkin do so even the way that
she speak yeah the way that she speaks
is super not casual so the way that I
learned how to speak Korean my Korean is
not that great it's very childish yeah
but I learned how to speak Korean from
her it's a very it's it doesn't I don't
know how to use like London my very well
so talking about is like the honorific I
see foreign form of speaking Korean cuz
my mom doesn't speak that [ __ ] to me so
when I first came to to k-town I only
knew how to say things in the way that
my mom would say things so I was just
[ __ ] sounding mad disrespectful to
everybody they're just like [ __ ] this
life [ __ ] this rude ass [ __ ] and
then a couple of my friends like bro you
you can't say that [ __ ] did you change
your vocabulary tonight correct I had to
learn it so even Marilyn understands
that too like sometimes when I speaking
to her parents she cracks up she goes
like Dan you sweet them really casually
and I'm like III don't know the
difference so you have to let me know do
they they're forgiving though they're
forgiving they're like they met your mom
and they're like ah well they also know
I'm their mother hotter I think they
also just happy that I can just speak
Korean in general oh so it's like most
people that they meet that are around my
age in my generation they don't they
can't speak Korean really yeah they they
just can't speak Korean so they're kind
of happy that they she met somebody that
can't speak Korean what are they doing
they're like they're not learning it at
home cuz I know like a lot of creams
that I know can actually speak I think a
lot of k-town Koreans can write a lot of
like that k-town like deep la area stuff
or if they're they are like first
generation they're fogs like cuz I'm a
fob as well you know because Mariel was
surprised when we first met when even
when we were first dating she was
surprised that I could speak Korean what
cuz a lot of her Korean friends can't we
can't like a lot of guys can't speak
Korean and it's cuz of the area that she
grew up in yeah so she's like oh wow I'm
surprised and what I mean by speak
Korean is to it like beyond just like I
dunno like and just saying oh yeah yeah
yeah like saying that I could actually
have a conversation with somebody in
Korean oh so she was kind of shocked
about that as she was surprised I could
recur in as well so with her parents it
was kind of like it was kind of cool
that's that's the relationship that we
had and so even when she met my mom like
my mom is very she's very her etiquette
isn't that great either so she she likes
you she'll [ __ ] slap you like she'll
just hit you in the back super [ __ ]
hard she's that kind of mom yeah she's
like cracking up she'll smack you in the
back slap you upside your head slap you
in the face slap you in the ass yeah
that's it that's affection right there
yeah yeah because when I see that ads is
like I understand I'm like let's say
like Asian mom thing when you say some
joke and she likes your jokes she smacks
you on your head yeah it's like yeah you
know I'm jumping the gun right now but
Liz like if this woman is comfortable
enough to do that around you I find that
to be a really really great sign I mean
she she likes you and also too if if
she's an older woman this is how she's
been in her own house mind you you're
going into her house yeah that's her
[ __ ] domain see the [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] floor if she wants you
understand what I'm saying so what did
she say yeah so she's saying like how do
I deal with it or like what should I do
yeah I guess like for her it's
problematic she has terrible etiquette
it's like the one thing that she hates
about her she goes she would literally
open her mouth wide to burp lift her
butt off the seat to [ __ ] [ __ ] funny
and talking detail about her bowel
movements including [ __ ] stains in her
pants that's all - that is [ __ ] funny
she even made an inappropriate comment
to her nephew while we were all playing
Jenga after Christmas dinner last year
his girlfriend they're both in their
late 20s was tapping at one of my blocks
and my boyfriend's mom turned to him
says does she flicked your dick like
that dawg that's okay hold on
you listen to us you like you probably
watch taking in the jokes that we make
is the same [ __ ] so I don't understand I
love that though like I wouldn't love my
mother-in-law to do that [ __ ] I know and
so this is why so if you're watching our
content right you're not it's like I
don't understand you like you like us on
the screen or what we're saying it's the
same [ __ ] we're the same jokes because
if I was a parent I'd be doing the same
[ __ ] though right so is it different
because you're getting entertained and
you don't really want that in your house
like I don't get it I guess like okay so
she says to which everyone responded
with shock and disgust let's see it I'm
not sure about everyone I know there's
no changing because half
yeah I know there's no change someone
who is almost 60 and I don't want to be
judgmental so how can I deal with this
what can I do to keep in mind do or keep
in mind so I don't continue to have
increasing frustration while I'm there
thanks so much love the show I love how
the mom isn't the prude and she is okay
put it this way it's much much better to
have someone very comfortable and maybe
a little edgy and maybe a little bad and
etiquette then to have someone who's
very controlling who's on your case on
your ass and making you feel
uncomfortable and making you feel
uncomfortable in the way where you're
controlled and you're maybe you're not
good enough and all that trust me it's a
lot better to have a mom that farts in
the house than a mom that look at looks
at you eat [ __ ] she's judging you and
saying hey what do you do for your
career are you good enough for my son
are you this and oh my god trust me if I
had the two extremes I would always
choose the mom that farts a hundred
thousand percent because what I see in
this is how I interpret is like she
actually cares about you she goes I
could be myself around you which is
really great yeah and by the way too and
I'm not [ __ ] on you on this but I'm
saying it for me let's say I was a 60
year old man and I'm doing [ __ ] the way
I want in my house and then you're like
that's disgusting don't do that my house
[ __ ] yeah I'll do whatever the [ __ ] I
want since the guy since that's my son
whose dick you're [ __ ] sucking right
now he has to deal with that [ __ ] guess
what you're family now now you got to
deal with my Dookie and my time and it's
like you know what I hear that's just -
which is like oh does you flick your
dick like that and you were shocked and
disgusted it's like I'll be like yo
that's [ __ ] hilarious it's all
interpretation you make jokes like that
all the time why is it shocking like if
you like that kind of entertainment yeah
it's like and also - is why does this
woman have to be put to your standard of
what proper is in her own household
because it's because you are visiting
her home right
yeah and that's true it's difficult for
me to kind of be on the side of her well
let me let me rephrase that
yeah because I get where
she's coming from it's not that I don't
understand it mm-hmm there are a lot of
like common sense rules that she's kind
of breaking and she's not being mindful
of other people's comfort yeah she's not
being a great house host right host me
right yeah so I get it because you
weren't raised that way but also here's
a great opportunity to be accepting of
people and really seeing them for who
they are like if you said that she's a
lovable great human being and all this
stuff like and maybe she might have a
little things that she might have traits
that make you cringe or whatever right
it's one thing to there's something
small yeah and she has like whatever a
mouth or whatever she or crazy jokes or
yeah it's just not she's not reading the
room but try to love her and understand
her and maybe even challenge yourself as
and this is an opportunity to look into
another person's lifestyle and how
things work for them and how comfortable
she can be in her own skin yeah cuz you
weren't raised that way maybe your mom
would never do the things that she does
but hey you're combining families
possibly if you guys get married or
whatever like you got to either learn to
enjoy it dude or you're gonna live with
this for the rest of your life and
you're gonna always be angry and
resentful because I you're right - and
you nailed it on the head when you said
even in what you wrote you're not gonna
be able to change a 60 year old woman
it's not gonna it's not going to happen
dude and if you wanted how I would take
this in perspective is that and you'd
like I just I just know what it feels
like to be on the other end of a parent
not accepting you that's the worst
that's it's one of the worst feelings
the fact that your she's there with open
arms and you can go there and show fart
in front of you that you gotta see the
beauty in that there is beauty in that
[ __ ] do because the opposite is you go
home you can't [ __ ] get along with
that parent mm-hmm they're constantly
judging you you feel uncomfortable in
the household not because they fart but
because they don't accept you
that's the worst [ __ ] feeling also -
it's like it's not something that you
really have to deal with if it's
something that makes you
that uncomfortable that you're willing
to risk that relationship that you have
with your I don't know future
mother-in-law your boyfriend's are your
boyfriend's mom that's probably
something that you could discuss with
your boyfriend and said like hey like
yeah is this something that you're okay
with - it makes me feel kind of
uncomfortable and if you guys discussed
it discuss it he says he's fine with it
yeah and then that's something that you
should I should talk amongst yourselves
first and it might take time because I
know that within my family they used
their their own kids as hostage meaning
like if they wanted to change the
behavior of their parents they would
limit their privileges with their
grandchildren Oh be like hey I don't
want to raise my kids in this
environment where you're [ __ ] making
these [ __ ] jokes you're farting around
that's not the type of environment I
want for my kids so if you want to see
us and if you want to see them you got
to check yourself those are the rules of
my home Yeah right if you don't bring
the babies to Grandma's home or if you
do bring the babies to Grandma's home
then grandma's got to check herself if
she argues then you withhold those
privileges so you got to understand how
to bargain with people and negotiate
with people this is the thing right most
people they don't know how to do it and
they know they'll be like well people
should just [ __ ] change out of the
goodness of their heart sad truth is it
doesn't happen that way most people can
try to be like hey grandma or hey mom I
don't like it when you're farting around
me mm-hmm can you stop some people might
try to be reasonable some people might
be like yeah sure whatever and then
don't forget again and they'll fart
because there's no consequence there's
no bargaining there's nothing that
they're gonna lose so you have to put
the pressure on people if they if you
really want them to change everything is
a deal everything is some type of
situation where you're like all right
you've got to change yourself because
what I want out of this relationship you
know what the thing too is I realized
when you were somebody to you you get a
whole package you never just get the
individual you get their whole family
and everything that comes with them yeah
that's what my mom told me that's right
and you just got a [ __ ] band a band
of hillbillies ma I mean and
I would much rather choose a band of
hillbillies than a judgmental
unaccepting group of people and yes and
it kind of feels like one or the other
it's like one can accept you and be
classy and whatever but you're not gonna
have the whole package yeah man and
could you imagine - because I'm you know
I'm a Korean American Korean people they
I think like religious Korean people
which is the type of Korean people that
I grew up in mind you I [ __ ] love my
culture to the to my very corn bones but
there is like a certain level of like
it's not just creepy but I think it's
just Asian people in general I see this
a lot in Chinese culture too where
there's like the certain level of
standard that you have to be in order to
be considered a respectable human being
yeah right and I think that that kind of
maybe is what you grew up with whether
you agree with it or not but it seems
like it's it's something that's
ingrained in you so when you see
something that rubs against your typical
belief that you grew up with you think
that it's uncultured or you think that
it's very rude or disrespectful but
that's also perspective as well - like
like I mentioned before you're in her
house
that's her household moves so if they're
fine with that [ __ ] then you should be
okay with it - mind you when you have
kids and maybe you don't want that
influence to affect your children that's
when the the chips change a little bit
that's when the cards change bit now you
could really control that but that's in
your household then you could choose
whether kids go over to Grandma or
Grandpa's house and that's when you
could say like Jo was saying like hey I
want the kids to come over but while
they're staying with you I don't want
you to talk about dick jokes and do all
other stuff like that's a little too
young for them so please just hold off
on that [ __ ] and if not then you got to
lay down the law yep but and then you
deprive them of that and that's
something that they can't live with I
guarantee you grandparents need to see
their grandkids you tell them you can't
see them they're gonna go oh no I'll
change I'll do anything
yeah and I'm wasn't I'm not somebody
that every parents parent [ __ ]
enjoyed I'm definitely not the dream kid
that they want coming into their
household yeah especially like
traditional Korean people they're just
like this guy curses all the time blah
blah blah blah and I even feel like with
Mario's parents they didn't really upset
me until like maybe like last year and
and that's the thing - most I feel like
in most cases people will judge you
first and it's probably you have to
audition and you can't you won't be
accepted even if you are great
and at least you don't have to go
through that you have someone who's
loving warm welcoming she might [ __ ]
talk [ __ ] about some sex jokes or she
might fart or whatever but [ __ ] that to
me is way better because the standard I
think is most people's parent like most
people's parents are looking at their
kids and who they date and in looking at
them as if are you good enough to be a
part of our family you already moved
past that yeah that's amazing that is
amazing it's hard to be judged like that
man like it's very difficult Muriel told
me the story once where her mom had a
very specific dream for her of the type
of Korean male that she wanted Muriel to
be with right and so when you sometimes
we're nearing these Korean churches and
this is like churches in general right I
always say churches is like the the
hospital for people who need like
spiritual healing so this is a huge
misconception where people think that oh
when you if you go to church these
Christian human beings they should be
perfect it's actually the opposite
people come to church to be healed by
whatever not just Church Buddhist
temples whatever right to be here so
broke and they bring eat it yeah yeah
it's a hospital people want to be healed
by this institution so a lot of the
times these people who are in church
though on the surface they may seem like
the best person or that they're supposed
to be they're actually not there's like
some of the worst human beings you'll
ever [ __ ] meet and they're trying to
be better yeah and so
Muriel's mom would try to set her up
with these guys who like in the Korean
textbook when you look at things and
obviously when another Korean parent
talks about their son they're going to
tell the best things about them yeah cuz
they don't even really know their kids
like that but I remember she told the
story where she was saying she was put
on a blind date once and her mom didn't
even know who this type of guy was but
she took it just for face value of oh
he's this guy he wants to be a doctor
he's gonna do this this Wow the guy
didn't even become a doctor later on
either he's a [ __ ] loser but the guy
took Mariel to like like this like bar
where you could like smoking it and [ __ ]
and it wasn't even like a nice dinner
it's like a shitty ass area he was super
disrespectful and rude and then Mariel
didn't go on a date with him again
afterwards and then Mariel got matched
mom I got a little upset her was like
you'll how come you didn't follow up
like he's gonna be a doctor he's a
really good
he goes to power do you know exactly
he's a really good guy and my moms like
do you know that where he took me to
like he took me to this place he was
like you'll say you know he smokes right
she goes he doesn't smoke he the smoke
why is she denying what Muriel saw yeah
and you know what sucks too is like at
that point - like I said Mario's mom is
fantastic I'm not saying anything bad
about her but at that time in her life
she had a very certain expectation of
what she wanted from a doctor which a
lot of Asian parents do have for their
kids
we're just parents in general and she
thought that this guy met this certain
standard and it kind of sucked from
Muriel at the time because I [ __ ] like
you don't even know this guy and you're
already on his side and you know not
mine yeah you know but a lot of yeah
you're right about the whole painting
the picture of Asian parents kind of
being so stubborn with the goal that
they want they don't think about what's
best for their kid this podcast is
brought to you by Skillshare I am all
about continuing to learn throughout my
whole life I refuse to be an old old man
that never wants to learn I have so many
hobbies I have so many things that I
want to do and I need the skills to do
it
and guess what I don't want to go to a
traditional former school learning that
I want to learn on my own accord my own
time short classes long classes whatever
will guess where sheesh what skill share
has that for you skill share is an
online learning community that offers
memberships with meaning with so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creative skill share
empowers you to accomplish real growth
my friends Skillshare
for those of you who don't know is an
online learning community where millions
come together to take the next step in
their creative journey thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and
curious people on tops including
illustration design photography video
freelance again more you guys already
know I take a lot of photos photos are
my thing well for those of you out there
that want to try to learn how to use a
DSLR take it at their DSLR other
fundamentals in DSLR photography that
right there will help you out the most
because you need to know the basis in
order for you to learn in order for you
to progress so check that out skill
share has been something that I really
do enjoy on my off time if I want to
learn something on my own on my own
schedule skill sure has that huge
library of just a bunch of knowledge so
it really helps me kind of take my hobby
to the to the next step and I enjoyed
very
very much explore your creativity and
get to three months of premium
membership sto share calm / brain that's
two whole months of unlimited access at
thousands of classes for free get
started and joined today by heading to
Skillshare calm / brain that's two three
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes at Skillshare comm / brain
yeah it's it's just like my dad had that
same expectation out of me like he he
had this dream of life of us living in a
multi-generational home I was gonna live
with him forever you're like you're too
annoyed yeah that's like why the [ __ ]
would I be there I was like are you out
of your [ __ ] mind
like you think you could live with me in
the same household are you [ __ ]
insane but he had a dream of us living
together in a house together the
grandkids running around
he has like his own house in the back
and then we could you know it's like dog
first of all where the [ __ ] is his money
coming from I mean like number two yeah
I wasn't told about this dream you just
assumed it was gonna happen yeah that's
not [ __ ] fair dude like are you
insane and because that's that's how a
lot of like Korean people do that they
live in intergenerational homes so it's
like ma big house or they have a house
in the back that's specifically for
Grandma around that's agents though a
lot of us don't move out yeah I was like
bro I would love that [ __ ] if you
weren't so far in yeah we all move is
yeah it's like cool well uh we're living
here now right yeah everyone moves in I
don't know if I could my mom knows too
that she doesn't want to live with me
she goes like I can't with you she goes
I [ __ ] hate you she was like I can't
live with you you would fight with me
every day though so you know for a fact
I just I just want you to be close like
a check up on you other than that like
you think she can live with your brother
no my dog my parents specifically can't
live with my brother not because of my
brother's habit so much is because my
parents still till this day try to baby
my only brother and it's [ __ ]
annoying to watch when I was in
Sacramento I had the flu I was dying I
was I felt with like a fever of like a
hundred and something shivering my ass
off and I was getting annoyed because I
could hear my dad just nagging my
brother on the other side and so when I
on the third day when I was feeling
better I still had a fever and body
chills my dad was like telling me he
goes like dude your brother he's being
so difficult I don't
Stan why he does his stuff and I
literally told my dad [ __ ] leave him
alone as I'm dying from the fever yeah
what do you mean I'm like I can hear
through the door
how annoying you're being he was like
well I don't like the way that he
responds to me I'll say let me ask you
something he is 35 right he's 35 years
old how annoying is it that every time I
brother makes a cough sneeze sniffle
fart yeah you act you ask if he needs to
go to the hospital he literally does
this my brother would burp right but he
goes you having this shet indigestion
duty medicine do you go to the hospital
dance 35 years old my brother gets up
from the seat he goes why he's our you
go in the bathroom why did your stomach
hurt what's wrong
damn he's panicked yeah and my brother's
like dude [ __ ] leave me alone shut
the [ __ ] up I'm 35 like let me know and
he's been doing that to my brother since
day one since he was a child
exactly he's been baby him since why was
he a fragile baby I don't know but my
mom told me too that you know that's
like what every parent says like I never
did that for you because I knew you were
strong I was like oh you just hated my
guts but like but my dad never he he
always my mom and dad always babied him
that way and you know he's a grown-ass
man but it still hasn't stopped so it
gets really [ __ ] annoying sometimes
when it's just like you know I'm just
trying to chill out let me breathe for a
second like but he farted and my bad my
bad my dad was like you have indigestion
and you go to a hospital
he farted I never farted before in his
life
that's [ __ ] funny yeah and I'm over
here with the fever didn't check on me
once why like [ __ ] this guy man but yeah
my brother was just like dude if you
didn't come to Sacramento for the
holidays I would have I would have
[ __ ] loaded or some like traumatic
past event like your brother was like
sick and he almost died as a child or
whatever that they are telling you guys
and they're just [ __ ] paranoid I
think they just think they don't know
that my brother's a lot more capable
than he seems cuz I think their level of
comparison is like me that the
problematic kid who did things his own
way and you know things turned out
pretty well for him and so my brother
was somebody who I think my older
brother is a very smart guy very
intelligent very empathetic he has a lot
of great qualities that I
don't have but the one thing that he
does have as a flaw is that sometimes he
lets the world beat him up and he stays
down hmm
he's not really used to a lot of
adversity and I think cuz a lot a lot of
great things happen to him and it just
came to him without him having to work
hard cuz it's because maybe your parents
kept rescuing my parents kept rescuing
them he was always he was always more
book-smart than I was very nice guy
good-looking dude and so when he's faced
with adversity sometimes he doesn't have
that ability to really fight for it
because my parents never let him [ __ ]
fight for it oh right or just like oh my
god we got to take him to the hospital
you farted exactly and so it may also
get upset at him sometimes when he's not
capable of doing these things but it's
like that's your fault and then they
destroy his confidence yeah you
handicapped him yeah like that's not his
fault like you and I do I got to
recently I was like how come you can't
take responsibility that some of the
qualities that you don't like in my
older brother your son is also actually
do because of the way that you raised
him you might accept that a stubborn ox
yeah it's like you got to accept that
like you babied him he's sometimes the
stuff that you see him that you don't
like it's also because of the way that
you treated him as an adult and as a kid
like it's hard for him to really
understand that because in this man he
goes I did the best that I could
I understand effort doesn't mean what
the result was though exactly he's all
like trying to defend himself man he's
kind of a kid yeah you know and a lot of
the qualities that my dad doesn't like
about him my brother is the stuff that
he has it's like those are your
qualities actually dude and my friend
fighting on his about his own
insecurities actually a hundred verses
that your brother is triggering [ __ ]
that he doesn't like about himself
mm-hmm that's whoa my dad and my brother
sometimes they clash horns a lot because
they they're actually very very similar
they're both very shy human beings
they're very reserved
they kind of like bottle up their
emotions a lot and so they my dad sees
that as a weakness because he sees that
in himself as well there's a lot of
things that he saw that my dad might
might his dad my grandpa [ __ ] up on is
a stuff that I used to get my ass beat
more because he saw the the terrible
qualities at my grandpa had and he saw
it in my behaviors and so he used to get
[ __ ] mad at me like for example like
my my grandpa just wasn't very
knowledgeable about
so he put his fate in the hands of other
people around him and because he did
that used to own this Tupperware a
business this pepero company where they
would make Tupperware lids and like
whatever what not very successful my dad
grew up with a lot of money when he was
super younger in korea in korea but he
trusted his money to other people they
took all of his money became bankrupt
and so when i didn't know things and I
wasn't knowledgeable about things my dad
would get mad at me he goes like do you
want to be just like your grandpa it's
like wow you're like pushing this [ __ ]
on me he's like got all these
insecurities that he's just lashing out
at for sure like and I can miss the
chill man yeah man and I think he's had
the crazy thing is he's actually chilled
out like 90% so could you imagine how
much worse he was when I was younger
like especially having a kid like me who
wanted who actually had the qualities
that he somewhat liked to which is me
being persistent but it wasn't
persistent in the stuff that he wanted
me to be persistent in you know what the
crazy thing is though him you know we
grew up with a lot of adversity and we
went through a lot of tension with our
family but looking back I'm like I'm
here today doing things that I want
because I fought for it [ __ ]
you know and I'm like well you know
gotta work I did complain about bad you
know parenting I did complete complain
about um you know the abusive
relationship or whatever but at the end
of the day man it all created me for
sure my ability to fight through if I
could take a [ __ ] punch from my dad I
could [ __ ] take a punch from the
world you know dog you know what's so
funny when I was in seventh and eighth
grade I got jumped by a couple of kids
and 101 was a kid that I stabbed in
third grade he still kept it all the way
till junior high because we split
schools but this kid jumped me and I
remember he tried to jump me with his
friends and they were swinging full clip
at me but then as a kid I was like
that's all you got [ __ ] I was
like do my dad literally just beat me
with a lead pipe yesterday like that
really didn't feel like it felt like
pillows yeah and I just wailed on this
[ __ ] this is nothing it felt
like nothing and I'm like damn I guess
it's true that what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger sometimes and that's
the metaphor to even life like yeah like
you could either let your path
trama beat you down and you stay down or
you could see it as well I went through
the worst so what else can happen now
what's the worst that can happen I went
through horrible [ __ ] so nothing can
take me down and so you start looking at
the world and life as oh man this is
easy this is fun
don't you think that's what really like
comedy did for us though like comedy
really allowed me to heal from a lot of
the things like I comma D more than I
did music because I saw the potential of
what it did for me as an individual
first same here because my first love
was music yeah but like with music
you're exposed you're expressing one
note and maybe some insight but with
comedy you can rewrite the story of how
you felt about something yeah music I
think you're capturing that moment how
you felt putting it into two song yeah
but like with comedy you have a tragic
memory yeah and you somehow change and
shift the perspective in so many
different ways that somehow something
that should have been traumatic or
hurtful ends up becoming the most
funniest thing and it becomes something
that everyone listens to and they find
joy from your trauma that's some
next-level [ __ ] yo here's some universal
truth about laughter and I think this is
why I really chose to stick with comedy
and then now we're doing this like
comedy podcasts or whatever which I
guess it's not really a comedy podcast
but we got laughs in the [ __ ] and we
can't resist making jokes yeah it is
exactly it's just I think about it like
this no matter what somebody goes to
whether you're poverty-stricken your
your life sucks bad things that happen
if there's something within a day that
allows you to laugh your [ __ ] ass off
right in that moment that you're
laughing you don't feel anything but joy
that's true that's what I love about
laughter and comedy is that when you're
in that moment [ __ ] laughing your ass
off you're actually not thinking about
like your car that broke down the
girlfriend that broke up with you the
boyfriend that treated you like [ __ ] no
your bills or whatever which you're only
focused on is laughing your [ __ ] ass
off it's like blessing enough yes when
you're busting a nut you're not thinking
about the bill you forgot to pay ticket
and then you just frozen in time yeah
that's the same with laughter yeah haha
you're not think I got a pill the basil
abit I got laundry still that I didn't
finish exactly man sometimes two with
this the same feeling when you come do
right when you bust the nut the only
thing you're thinking about is [ __ ]
get that [ __ ] on our face goddammit you
[ __ ] on the bus oh my god you know
it's funny like I I kind of thought
about this [ __ ] the other day is like
when you when you're kind of like
hooking up with the girl
like you don't really think so much
about like the disrespect of what it's
like to come on a girl's [ __ ] face
but when you're in love with somebody
you think about it you're like I love
this woman they all know I'm gonna do
this like I was like when I was younger
too it's like you just couldn't wait
it's like I just can't face I don't know
why I like I don't know what guys like
that [ __ ] so much what the [ __ ] is it
about just [ __ ] just I don't know
because I had that finish all the way up
until high school and it disappeared
completely yeah
it doesn't do anything anymore and I
realized that I have these phases man
it's crazy I'll really get into
something and it just disappears and it
comes back after years later but yeah
it's like that one [ __ ] porn clip
that you saw a while ago that was so
[ __ ] dope and then you forgot about
it and then you came back to it and
they're like this is brand-new again I'm
so glad I found this clip I'm so I
actually had one of those moments
recently you don't have a playlist nah I
don't like porn that much to have a
playlist but I was like watching porn
like like a few days ago and it was this
clip that I saw that I saw years ago and
you know I it was like one of those like
Nick because I don't look at titles so I
don't know what the search for for it if
you're like this but it popped up but I
was like this was the Holy Grail this
was what I was looking for and now I
know the keywords to search for tall I
just think it was so amazing it made me
feel so good it's like I found a
thousand dollars and in a duffle bag on
the floor
there's always that one that got away
and then sometimes they come back yeah I
was like this is because it was it was a
girl that
wasn't a pornstar so she didn't have a
[ __ ] that's the only way that you
could find this is through descriptive
words right
which I think it was like [ __ ] I
think that the [ __ ] I don't know I wrote
it down somewhere just so I could go
back to it later but it was like
something about this guy having like a
six-inch dick [ __ ] his girl but it's
not a success it's like a big [ __ ]
dick yeah but the girl is [ __ ] cute
yeah and I was like this is this is this
cute ass [ __ ] girl did and I found
her again good I found my first love it
was the Holy Grail yeah I was like this
right here though is amazing man you
know why it was so hard to find that
clip it's because there's too much porn
out there I had a oh my god through all
this [ __ ] so much I just came out by
happenchance
it was just I was like my first love so
much it's crazy how much there is you're
right though
when you mention it's on it on a [ __ ]
YouTube about how incest porn is in its
it's raised all incest porn yeah it's
all that shit's weird [ __ ] my
step-brother like it looks like the and
it's like the hottest girls are only in
those incest porn it must be like the
money getting thing right now it POW
it's the most popular man there's
something happening in society right now
where everyone wants to [ __ ] their
sleeping sister like what the [ __ ] is
going on not only that it's like stepmom
and stepsister [ __ ] me weird dude or
like stepdad [ __ ] sister I had to uh
now I just I kind of just block out the
title and I just have to watch the porn
yeah but what about when they're like
hey brother Oh like they have this who
the [ __ ] talks like that no nobody goes
hey brother hey stepbrother
no no volume now I just watch and I just
fill in the gaps because it's so we I
feel like to that that level of
perversion it's it's kind of like when
porn was a little more mild
you just had a watch porn like you know
back in then we were kids we just needed
one rip out of a Playboy yeah I just had
a look at a face and titties and a [ __ ]
and I jack off and I'm fine but now that
next level is this crazy [ __ ] so people
are ready for the next level of
stimulation it's like a gateway drug now
there's gonna be giraffe [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] a draft
there's some weird [ __ ] dude tips
show me this [ __ ] funny porn which
how much to send you later first of all
this Japanese of course
do you know what this [ __ ] porn was
mmm
I never laughed so hard in my life so
this girl is on a porn set right she's
tied up on a on a an office chair like
this [ __ ] out tits out everything right
and the director goes cut cut cut cut
because he's the behind the scenes so it
was kind of like behind the scenes not
really alright so they're doing this
like weird scene or one of the other one
other porn actresses she basically goes
into like this room or trailer or
something and the trailer [ __ ]
explodes with the girl in there Wow
right so she dies right but even though
her friend just dies they go we still
gotta shoot this scene so this girl is
bawling cried getting [ __ ] in the ass
in the mouth [ __ ] she's crying and then
after where she comes the girl it was a
prank she goes just kidding I'm still
alive at the girls bawling crying cuz
she thought her best friend died oh my
god she has like come on her face and
she takes her cover she wipes it on her
friend's face oh my god one of the one
of the weirdest porns I've ever seen
what behaving okay that fetish is like
humiliation times ten what the [ __ ] who
thought of that [ __ ] dude
well Japanese love prank shows because
that sounds like a prank show in itself
yeah it's like hey let's blow up a whole
building and then like let's get the
reaction of this person how much money
do they spend on the ballistics of that
[ __ ] dude I don't know they [ __ ] TNT
that [ __ ] like it actually exploded like
straight-up they would do some [ __ ] like
that
and the girls crying and she's getting
fun and some guy comes and starts
[ __ ] her and then starts coming on
her face oh my god I always send you
that [ __ ] well there's really cute Craig
but it was so [ __ ] funny I couldn't
stop laughing about how ridiculous as
well what the [ __ ]
so there are guys out there that get
horny awful watching girls cry though
they get off that [ __ ] yeah it's kind of
weird there's like dude I saw this one
on Twitter it went viral it was this guy
going around and he was like super he
was acting this girl like hey are you
sick right now she goes yeah he goes
what's York off like is it really Flemmi
or whatever and then she messaged him
back
you better not be jacking off to this
[ __ ] and then she screen capped all of
his Twitter messages that he was sending
out like I love girls who have really
deep Flemmi coughs like girls that cough
really hard like turn me on and like he
has the weirdest limit of [ __ ] talk to
people I'm so [ __ ] glad all right
people think I'm a [ __ ] hardcore
pervert but at the end of the day I'm
pretty vanilla compared to a lot of the
guys out there and on top of that I
think the more open you are about your
perversion the less perverted you are
yeah when you hide it but looking on it
sounds really [ __ ] creepy even if I
like the same things as that dude Yeah
right so the thing is there's a lot of
creepy creepy porn out there and I don't
like all the really creepy stuff
yeah that's I'm not trying to jack off
to a [ __ ] bondage to girl that's
crying because her best friend just died
some people looking off I was talking
about like I came in Jake and he was
like I said I don't watch porn as much
as I used to which is true like I don't
like I was like the last time I watched
porn not too busy I want to watch more
porn oh that's the most when it was like
four or five days ago right and then
before that it was like two weeks so
it's like it's very intermittent yeah I
mean it's like when I'm in the mood to
watch it too damn busy now yeah like I
just like don't but when I'm home all
day like a [ __ ] college student
that's there's nothing in jacket jacket
and studying that's all I'm doing
I got time today baby hey I'm not the
wax went off like 17 times that's a
different world yeah when I had nothing
to do what else look what else am I
gonna do and I'm gonna go out get some
Sun and then we'll go back home and I'm
a [ __ ] wax like wax it off like it
like I've never jacked off in my life
before this is when I wish I was a woman
sometimes because they can do it without
being messy mmm for us it's a whole
[ __ ] event for sure and then we get
tired like we gotta go to sleep right
but girls they can [ __ ] DJ it off
anywhere and everywhere
still one time went out this was all
super I was like was in high school
after that what grade I was in but
that's not really important but it was
in high school and I was jacking off in
the [ __ ] shower but when I was in
high school I used to take really really
really hot showers Oh like Ronan yeah so
this was like even if it was in the
summer so this was during the summertime
it was already hot as [ __ ] Sacramento
gets like 170 degrees I was taking a hot
shower and I was
but there for some reason II was taking
me before ever to come but then I
remember I was trying to jack off too
hard just cuz I I wanted to nut and I
remember that I couldn't nut for some
reason I don't know what the [ __ ]
reason was but I was so determined that
I had a [ __ ] nut even if I if I
didn't technically didn't seem like it
was the right time I just kept going at
it but I did it so hard I [ __ ] like
keeled over from like the heat from a
heat stroke my god and just put so much
pressure to my brain oh my god blacked
out blacked out for a second I slip and
I hit my head oh what the [ __ ] are you
doing good I was like this is the most
looser thing ever I was so stubborn that
I had to just [ __ ] nut I was like
that's that's because Davis ho doesn't
give up that's right [ __ ] quitter
dude no Tim was saying that [ __ ] we're
like he's like Tim doesn't quit and he's
like so if his friends still start
jacking off and they get bored in
between and they stop and then he's like
I don't quit I just come no matter what
that's what it is baby I was like I've
already started this [ __ ] I'm gonna make
sure that I finish oh [ __ ] half ass
is what you are exactly dude and I
bashed my head onto the [ __ ] this
shower door and then I am and I
basically passed out for a second I
think the more harder you try do you
actually don't come and then when you
exactly but when you don't want to come
is when you [ __ ] bus fast because
when I'm actually [ __ ] sometimes I'm
like well I can't I why can't I last
longer
like when I jacking off and I don't want
to come when I I feel like that that
control parts a huge thing because I
even from me like that's why I think I
foreplay a lot because like it makes it
last a little longer oh yeah yeah my
foreplay is very important for you but
there's also times where I'm just
pounding and I can't come and I'm like
oh I just want to comes like a finish
what's [ __ ] happening like most girls
who they don't want it to last hella
long yeah but it's a mental thing man
it's all mental because the more you
like the girl the the way quicker that
you [ __ ] bust yeah they try to
impregnate that [ __ ] that's like trying
to keep her around forever your
psychology is like go [ __ ] keep her
around for like [ __ ] well guys I hope
that helped your situation out a little
bit
we went right the inappropriate nasty
time there's a funny thing is she's like
I don't you is that how you flicked your
[ __ ] guy's dick right there head and
then that's what we were talking about
see we can't help it dude just accept
the fact that she really likes you and
then she could be herself around you
also her house her rules when you have
kids later on you'll be able to probably
shift it a little bit but for now just
enjoy the fact that you're accepted and
it's such a wonderful thing to be
accepted by someone's parents yeah
especially that alone is so awesome man
it sounds like an Asian parent to me
she's Asian I'm assuming she's my god
but it sounds like I don't know it
reminds me my mom that's why I've seen
that in inappropriate stuff from Asian
culture I haven't I've been into a lot
of Latino houses whatever they're much
more conservative
yeah hyper Catholic yeah yes so like
sexual jokes I've seen a lot from Asian
families yeah
but not we know families like Bhutan
dude naina yes hell yeah if they're
supposed to be Catholic too
yeah but but they don't care but I don't
care if I see the lumpia I have to bite
so alright guys well that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
remember every Thursday he's gonna be me
and that Joe Jitsu Kesey
yeah and uh comments below Spotify all
that stuff leave a four five five five
five five star and we'll see you all
next time thank you very much bye bye